yet Allah Allah
this is Boko Haram's leader Abubakar
Shekau the man responsible for
kidnapping two hundred-plus majoring
girls and here he's mocking the bring
back our girls campaign he says he won't
return the girls until the military
brings back his captured men but
international support for the girls
remains strong Malala yousufzai the
Pakistani teenager who Taliban members
shot in the head for wanting an
education actually came to Nigeria to
push for their return she met with
family members of kidnapped children and
with President Goodluck Jonathan asking
him to save the girls and protect others
from being abducted and my birthday wish
this year is to speak up for the
Nigerian guys and to see my sisters who
are under the abduction of Boko Haram to
see them returning back to their homes
[Music]